[Musique]
le président du Département rencontre
Ambroise Fayol vice-président de la
Banque européenne d'investissement au
sein du collège Roquefeuille un
établissement qui a bénéficié d'un
financement de la BEI à hauteur de 65
millions d'euros la BEI c'est une banque
publique
européenne qui finance des projets
d'investissement qui sont considéré
comme particulièrement intéressant pour
l'Europe et ce qui est aujourd'hui
particulièrement intéressant c'est les
projets
d'infrastructure notamment
lesinfrastructures scolaires qui
intègrre parfaitement toutes les
dimensions de du changement climatique
et ce nouveau collège
ici il est extrêmement intéressant de ce
point de vue-là un collège modèle qui
intègre notamment des équipements
bioclimatiques une gestion des déchets
de la restauration une optimisation du
bilan carbone et la plantation d'une
microforêt au sein de ces espaces
d'autres collèges sur l'île
bénéficieront d'un accompagnement de la
BEI dans leur réflexion à venir et c'est
un signe de confiance de confiance dans
les institutions Réunionnaises et
notamment dans le département de La
Réunion parce que bien évidemment nous
avons en charge l'action sociale mais le
département est aussi un aménageur du
territoire le département investit dans
des routes le département investit dans
la transition écologique le département
investit dans l'eau mais secteur
essentiel le département investit dans
l'éducation et lorsque nous av av
construit ce collège de Roquefeuille ici
à Saint-Giles bah c'était en zone sèche
il a fallu imaginer et tenir compte des
enjeux climatiques et c'est pour cela
que la BI est avec nous la Banque
européenne d'investissement un
partenaire du département dans
l'aménagement de ces établissements
scolaires mais également pour une partie
de ses équipements
[Musique]
culturels